England oh how we roared  [Applause]  in clubs  parks  homes across the country  Millions watched as the lionesses made  history  it is they brought and they brought her  home right this weekend we can see that  women's football is coming home  of course there were twists and turns  along the way  in Lancashire learning early that being  an England fan is never easy  how did you feel though when Germany  scored I didn't I thought that it was  really bad and I was I didn't have much  faith in England then it's a bit of a  roller coaster  but when England did score this time to  win what a moment  what a moment to share with young  players across the country the lionesses  win more than just a game of football to  these girls it's a moment of history but  I think they're gonna remember forever  and it is  oh  in Kent slightly older players no less  delighted  [Applause]  [Applause]